2666 is the best book I've ever read and
it's not even close. In fact, it's a
book that means a lot to me personally.
And before talking a little bit about
the structure of the book, I will tell
you my story about it. So, I grew up in
Mexico, but I did my four years of
college in Burlington, Vermont, and
there's not really many Spanish speakers
there. So, it's something I definitely
miss dearly. And I decided to read in
Spanish a little more in order to just
keep that sort of connection with my
language besides just calling family and
friends. I had a few books I had bought
here and there and ordered. But one day
I was actually walking through a used
bookstore and I saw just this one book
in Spanish that was at the end of the
other languages section and that was
2666. I didn't have any idea about this
book or who Roberto Wano was. I simply
saw the sheer magnitude of this book,
the sheer page count, and I was a little
intimidated and very curious. And I read
the back of the book and I was very
hooked. I wanted to know what this was
about, what all five parts did. And I
calculated based on how many days I had
left in my very last semester of college
versus the pages left in the book, how
many I would have to read a day to
finish it before leaving college. It was
about 40 pages a day, which would be a
challenge, but it would be something
that I was more than willing to take.
So, I left with that book and I started
reading it and I was immediately hooked
and I kind of smashed through that 40
pages a day goal. Honestly, I finished
it maybe a month early because it was
just that good. What Bologano does that
is super interesting is for many of his
novels such as 266, but also Nazi
literature in the Americas and even in
the Savage Detectives is he creates a
literary corpus that is fictional but
makes the world feel so alive. And you
have people that are passionate about
these kinds of poems, literature, etc.
who just feel so relatable because
there's people you've met like that and
the way it's all interconnected is just
so beautiful. It reminds me so much of
the authors of the Latin America boom
and he is a little closer to that
generation of course even though his
books came later on but it just gives
you such a different blend of it that is
a little more grounded. Bologano is a
very complex person born in Chile but
also grew up in a large part in Mexico
and did a lot of his professional life
there and also eventually had his
children in Spain. So very interesting
international person of course very well
read and that was really cool because
you get all sorts of points of view that
are very well informed all about Europe
all about different parts of Latin
America but really his vivid
descriptions of this fictional city in
Mexico Santa Teresa is what really
really shook me to the core because
having grown up in Mexico it was like
being taken back home the way everything
was described that includes the good and
the bad you know it includes vivid
descriptions of a beautiful plaza with a
church in the middle and whatnot, which
is basically every little tiny town that
you go to visit on vacation or just the
way the streets are structured and the
different neighborhoods where you can
really picture yourself there if you
know how Mexican city is usually
structured. But also, there's the fourth
part of the book called the part of the
crimes where these horrible crimes that
happen against women are described in a
very sort of noneotional
excruciating detail. And this goes on
for hundreds and hundreds of pages. And
yet you simply cannot stop reading. You
get some insight into what the police
does and how it addresses it, such as
blaming other people who committed other
crimes and being like, "Yeah, they
totally also got rid of these women in
the process, which mirrors reality a
little too much. And Mexico is one of
the countries with the most feministic
happening to the point that many
Mexicans pretty much at least know a
victim of a crime like that. In some
way, this whole part gives a voice to
all the disappeared. And those
disappeared fluctuate in numbers because
then the way we're counting them changes
every single period. Really, there used
to be hundreds of thousands. Apparently,
there's less right now, but that's
really because the government changed
the way it counts. Not really, because
there's less disappeared people. And
this book shows a little microcosm of
that where things just kind of happen
and the authorities are none the wiser,
just like in real life. And yet the
people who find themselves in these
cities where horrible things are
happening have such beautiful intricate
lives you know and that shows that every
person is a story and every person has
their passions every person has their
complexities. Be the scholars in the
very first part who are fascinated with
the literary corpus of this fake author
called Benovon Archimaldi and they end
up in Mexico in their search for him and
what he represents. Be it the Mexican
scholar that they meet in this fictional
city and his daughter and the struggle
that he has gone through finding a sense
of belonging and raising his daughter in
such a horrible place. Be it Fate, the
American boxer that visits for a boxing
match that wasn't really his passion and
ends up intersecting with the daughter
of the scholar in the previous part. Be
it every person from every crime who had
a job, who had a family, even this
fictional world, which mirrors everyone
who is a victim of a crime in real life,
who has a job, who has a family, who has
a story, or be at the final part which
talks about the life of the person who
actually is Ben Chimaldi and actually
brings it all together in the end. It is
such a beautiful and intricately told
story that really shows you the value of
all these individual experiences and yet
touches on so many real things with such
sensibility. I even met a person once in
the Spanish department of a local
university who read this book and it
changed her life and now she works for
women's advocacy groups in Mexico. So,
it's not only me that this amazing book
has changed the life of. And I still
think about it so often, even though
it's been 5 years since I first read it,
and I've only really read a few excerpts
since then, but I just can't stop
thinking about it. And it's not really
easy to recommend because the subject
matter isn't the happiest, especially
once you get to the largest part where
all the crimes are described. And of
course, giving someone a gargantuan book
of about 1,300 pages isn't the easiest
ask, especially knowing that everyone is
busy. But that's why if you happen to
find yourself in this video, I would
highly recommend you try it out just
because you may find deeper meaning in
here. So, thank you Roberto Walano for
taking me home in 266 with everything
good and bad about it and perhaps
reminding me that since I left, I've
never been the same. And perhaps that's
okay because just like everyone else, I
have my own story. Thanks for watching.